a late night has really gone downhill
since Jay Leno left Stephen Colbert has
a lot to say if about the potential 2024
presidential race because right now
Donald Trump not doing very very well
right now Ron DeSantis doing much better
but Stephen Colbert
he's already looking ahead to what
happens if DeSantis takes over Trump new
Wall Street Journal poll says that in a
hypothetical GOP Primary matchup
DeSantis beats the former president 52
percent to 38 percent
yay
also maybe boo it's hard to know who to
root for here it's like a poll between
gonorrhea and a slightly more racist
gonorrhea
this is
apologies to gonorrhea
gosh Donald Trump Donald Trump is Hitler
Donald Trump is the worst person to ever
hold the presidency he it's not just
that we hate all the Republicans and
conservatives Donald Trump is uniquely a
threat he's a fascist he's a Nazi we
have to stop Donald Trump
but Rhonda Santos is just as bad and I
told you this you know I hate to say I
Told You So I said this all the way back
in 2016.
they're all pretending that Trump is the
unique case
by the time Trump leaves office that
it's going to be the good old days oh
Donald Trump was bad but he wasn't as
bad as
insert the name of the next Republican
just like they did to George W Bush when
George Bush was president he was Hitler
now he's all the good old days George W
bush just the same thing with George H.W
bush they did the same thing to Ronald
Reagan they called him a white
supremacist and a Nazi and a skinhead
and all the rest of it I guess he
couldn't be a skinhead because he had
such a beautiful head of hair and so
right now actually the only silver
lining for Donald Trump in what's been
generally a pretty bad political news
cycle for him vis-a-vis the Republican
primary and Ron DeSantis is they haven't
really opened fire on DeSantis yet
so DeSantis is doing very very well in
the polls but the moment that they start
to turn their Firepower on Ron DeSantis
you were going to see those numbers come
down I'm not saying it's going to be
fair it's really never fair when the
media do that that is the game that they
play speaking of rolling with the
punches
a house Republican representative Carlos
Jimenez
is urging Elon Musk to move Twitter to
Florida
not to move the Twitter digital platform
he's doing lots of moves there but to
move the physical headquarters to
Florida I think this would be a great
great move what Ximena says is quote
I'm writing to you as the former mayor
of Miami-Dade County who now has the
distinct honor of representing my
community in Congress we want to
encourage you to explore our free state
of Florida and make the move to relocate
Twitter to Miami-Dade County
uh
this would solve a lot of musk's
problems if he moved the headquarters
from San Francisco to Miami or something
that would solve a lot of musk problems
you remember right now musk is being
investigated because he he brought some
mattresses to the office for overworked
employees who want to take a quick nap
while he's being investigated for that
the government in San Francisco in
California obviously very very hostile
to musk they're going to continue to
launch investigations they're going to
pass laws to punish him and so what he
should do is move to Florida
it is a lesson that I've been trying to
drive home for a while but now we're
seeing it play out in real time
politics is not just your friends online
politics is not just about your Affinity
groups and
some some Meetup chat or something like
that politics is about a political
Community man is a in in some degree a
physical being and so the political
Community is also where we live if Elon
musk's moves from California to Florida
you will have a much easier time
conducting business just like the daily
wire has had a much easier time
conducting business when we move from LA
to Tennessee just like all sorts of
businesses have had a much easier time
since they moved from Florida to from
California to Florida from California to
Texas from California to Tennessee Elon
now is the time to do it it's going to
be a lot easier to move because you've
fired or allowed to quit huge numbers of
the staff you're selling off a lot of
the merch Elon is probably several steps
ahead of us in planning this out already
but let's do it it would also seriously
help the culture War because we have to
show these people that there are
consequences to their terrible policies
and their terrible government take their
money away take their power centers away
I don't like the idea that three or four
entities control the Public Square
especially because they're semi-private
entities but I would feel a hell of a
lot better if not all of those entities
were based in Silicon Valley surrounded
by crazy Libs I would feel a lot better
if at least one of those entities
even if it's the smallest one
we're based in a conservative state
speaking of the GOP
there's a big explosive report
this report is out from Red State
says that
the RNC has been spending tons of money
and it's largely a political attack on
Ronald McDaniel who is the current
chairman of the Republican National
Committee I assume this is part of the
campaign right now there's a power
struggle who's going to be the next GOP
chairman is Ronald McDaniel going to
continue to serve is harmy Dillon who's
a friend of ours a California Republican
lawyer is she going to become the new
head of it there was a rumor that
Mercedes schlapp who's a former Trump
official who is married to match lap
have the American conservative Union
that she might run
what is it regardless of who's behind it
it's obviously an attack on Ronald
McDaniel and I have to say there are
many reasons to attack the RNC and the
House GOP leadership and the Senate GOP
leadership this one seems a little bit
weak to me if you look at the money that
was spent on private jets the money that
was spent on limousines luxury Retreats
Broadway shows you know it all sounds
really bad in the headline it's not a
ton of money
the money that was spent on private jets
half a million dollars
that's what 10 flights
10 to 15 flights that's really not a ton
of money over this period of time over a
year
for a major American political party to
spend on chartered flights because
sometimes to get to fundraisers to get
to big events to get there on time to
places where they don't have commercial
flights I don't know that just doesn't
seem crazy to me
the floral arrangements food and
beverage alcohol again it sounds really
bad they spent 36 500 on alcohol well
yeah they're throwing events they're
raising money I this this seems a little
bit weak to me
I mean all All is fair and Love and War
and politics but the reasons to go after
the RNC are the failure of the RNC to
support good candidates to win elections
to counter the Democrats strategies in
terms of ballot harvesting in terms of
changing the laws in certain states to
to benefit one party over the other
that's that's why one would go after
them but spending a little bit of money
on booze at fundraisers I don't know
that that doesn't do a whole lot for me
the rest of the show continues now I
have got a great
written mailbag question from a retired
Jewish Christmas tree salesman I'm very
excited to answer I just see that name
right up there at the top so you'll have
to head over to the members block to
hear that question and answer it's also
fake headline Friday so fake headline
Friday is of course where Mr Davies
gives me five headlines and I need your
help to understand which one is the fake
headline we will be doing that right now
please come over and help me if you're
not a member click the link in the
description and join us
[Music]
foreign